hello everyone and welcome to a really
fun game uh from 1951 it was played in
live of ukraine and it really shows how
uh even very strong players even
grandmasters can fall uh for some traps
this this wasn't even a trap this was
just a self-made trap and uh well one of
the players fell into it uh i don't have
a photo of
mr mikhail alexander which bunch of
smolovsky so of course we have uh our
hoodie guy here and we are slovrogozin
is a very well known uh figure in the
chess world so i'm sure you guys are not
hearing about him for the first time but
before we check out the game and it's
very short so you guys can uh well easy
easily remember it and impress everyone
uh
after this game i will have a very two
very short announcements uh so stay
tuned for that but let's check out the
game now so ragozin has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 that we have c5
knight to f3 we have knight to c6 and d4
so just to open sicilian defense we have
captures captures and now g6 the
accelerated dragon variation we have
knight to c3 uh and now a bishop to g7
putting pressure on the knight here so
white defenses bishop to e3 d6 and now
bishop to a2 so this is all very
standard stuff even today uh knight to
f6 and both players castle so castles
castles and queen to d2 preparing the
standard bishop to h6
maneuver and nowadays bishop to b7 is
considered the main move but okay here
we have knight to g4 also very strong
you're saying either i'm going to win
this bishop or you will capture on g4
and then i'm going to win your light
square bishop so this is exactly what
goes in place uh he plays bishop
captures we have bishop captures and now
knight to d5 white uh improves the
position of the knight and also prepares
c4 uh to improve this uh knight here uh
so what do you do we have rook to c8
black continuous development and c4 now
we have bishop back to d7
and b3 you do not want anything on this
diagonal and also you will shift your
rook over to c1 probably bring this rook
over to d1 and you don't want this
bishop to have any target so here we
have knight to e5 uh safest for black
would just be to capture on d4 but
that's like saying okay i i don't really
have anything i'm just gonna capture for
for capture sake but instead black goes
knight to e5 and maybe he's hoping that
the white might play something like f4
and then he can play knight g4 and then
maybe trade the knight for the bishop
but white doesn't care he just plays h3
takes away the g4 square from the knight
and here we have e6 finally chasing away
this knight from this very uh strong
square and uh it is as of move 14 that
this position has never been reached
again if you guys are wondering uh
knight back to c3 and now queen to a5 so
all very standard ideas now the knight
can't move otherwise black will trade
queens and as the white is controlling a
bit more space um that that will be
advantageous for black so rook after d1
white continues development and now a6
we have rook 8 to c1
and now rook f2 d8 and you'll see how
this rook after d8 although a fine move
in this position uh will
be the downfall of black very soon here
white plays bishop to h6 he offers the
trade of dark square bishops as it's um
pretty much
what you do when you have the queen d2
bishop to e3 battle you want to play
bishop to h6 and trade off the dark
square bishops and now black could play
something like bishop captures an h6 he
could play knight to c6 he could play f6
there are many moves here that are
possible but black played the absolute
worst move okay absolute worst would be
some like queen captures an a2 maybe but
okay he played bishop to h8
and now the position is completely lost
for him so feel free to pause the video
and impress everyone with your vast
knowledge while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on possessing such
vast knowledge and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course knight to d5 and you can see how
everything just uh fits uh well together
uh black of course resigned in this
position as there is nothing more to be
done here he will either lose the queen
on a5 or he will get checkmated knight
to e7 will be checkmate because now when
the bishop moved
our dark square bishop controls g7 and
f8 and let's say we capture the queen
knight to e7 is checkmate or if you want
to stop checkmate then you're going to
lose the queen there's no way to defend
both the queen and prevent checkmate and
this rook the d8 move prevents the queen
from retreating to the d8 square from
where the queen could be
guarding these seven squares so very
very
tough game for black but it happens even
on this level so once again
congratulations to everyone who found it
and i mentioned that i will have two
short announcements so uh regarding the
cake defy arena that we had a few days
ago it will be continued but it will be
continued in january we don't have the
exact date yet uh january 3rd or maybe
january 4th i will keep you guys
informed and the tournament will
continue at the exact point where the
servers started
you know playing around
so not
when they crashed but a few minutes
before that at that exact point the
tournament will resume uh so the there
will be at least an hour of the arena
left with uh
the standings and everything else as it
was so that's uh
one uh announcement i wanted to make and
another one is this year we're also
going to be making uh the chess
brings everyone together video so for
those of you who don't know or haven't
been follow following the channel uh for
that long uh you guys just send me a
photo or a video of you teaching anyone
else how to play chess it can be your
your uh
children your mother your father your
grandmother your grandfather so uh
literally anyone i i've received a lot
of photos of um uh people playing uh
chess with it with their dogs with their
cats i think there was even a rabbit at
some point so please don't send me
viruses uh that's not cool i mean
everything gets scanned of course but
it's still it's still kind of annoying
and last year i received no viruses so i
was very happy about that and i hope
that that will continue in this year as
well if you guys haven't seen those
videos do check them out i will put them
in the description below the first three
links you will see are the previous uh
three versions we've made of checks it
just brings people together so if you
guys enjoy that and you want to be a
part of that this year okay it probably
will not be released this year probably
next year in january uh you are welcome
to uh send us a photo or a video and
also feel free to include a message uh
and send it to the email that is also in
the description below okay the first
thing will be the email and then the
three links so you guys can check it out
so yeah that's it that's the game uh
ended the announcements i hope you guys
enjoyed that
i would like to thank matteo martini
andre lazario eric mumford timothy rosen
and david groskin for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on everything in
chess world and of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day